d l'absurdité de leur message la parole
est à monsieur il va albarello merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre le 26
octobre dernier vous étiez encore
ministre de l'intérieur
lorsque je vous ai interrogé au sujet
des prières de rue se déroule en cinq
fois par jour à lagny sur marne devant
une école et dans un quartier
prioritaire de la politique de la ville
vous m'avez répondu textuellement que
les policiers ont pour instruction de
faire cesser tous les troubles à l'ordre
public
or votre ancien directeur de cabinet
écrit au maire de l'année le contraire
il affirme que selon les informations
communiquées par le préfet de
seine-et-marne les conditions juridiques
je le cite ne semblent pas réunies pour
mettre fin par la force aux prières qui
se déroulent quotidiennement
il ajoute en raison d'une faible
affluence le lieu demeure accessible aux
locataires pendant les prières et qu
aucune nuisance excessive ne peut être
démontré enfin que ces prières ne sont
pas visibles depuis l'école publique
monsieur le premier ministre qui dit
vrai vous votre ancien directeur de
cabinet du préfet qu'est ce qu'une
nuisance non excessives
faut-il que le trouble à l'ordre public
dépendent de l'affluence d'une onde et
délinquants en vérité depuis votre
réponse du 26 octobre dernier
rien n'a changé rien n'a été fait par
vos services pour faire cesser ces
prières de rue celle ci continue et des
habitants sont même réveillé à l'appel
de la prière
le soir les prieurs font du prosélytisme
à l'égard des enfants amenés sur place
mais le plus cocasse sinon le plus
scandaleux est la solution préconisée
par le ministère de l'intérieur
voulant que la mairie met un local à la
disposition des musulmans de la nuit
quelle incohérence
il y a un an vous fermer la mosquée de
la nuit aujourd'hui vos collaborateurs
demande
l'affectation d'un look à la prière on
marche sur la tête
alors monsieur le premier ministre ma
question est simple qu'on ferait vous
cesser définitivement ses prières de rue
à lagny peut-être que vos nouvelles
fonctions vous permettront d'être plus
efficace la parole est à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur bruno le roux
le député albarello je prends votre
question bien entendu au titre des
responsabilités qui sont les miennes et
je sois qui apportait une réponse
précise
la dissolution d'une association il y à
une dissolution de trois associations à
la nuit et fermeture de la mosquée la
dissolution d'une association est une
mesure particulièrement importante
distincte de la fermeture provisoire
d'un lieu de culte comme l'a reconnu le
conseil d'état la situation de la
mosquée de la nuit présentait bien ce
caractère de gravité puisque l'on
continuait en 2016
aïe propager l'idéologie de l'ancien
imam mohammed admis parties en egypte en
2014 consistant à rejeter les valeurs de
la république et apprenez le djihad armé
des membres de l'association avaient
activement participé au recrutement et à
l'acheminement de jeunes français vers
la zone
ico syrienne enfin des perquisitions
avaient révélé l'existence d'une école
coranique clandestines au domicile du
président de l'association il fallait
donc impérativement dissoudre ces
associations et fermer la mosquée qui
servait de base je dis ça pour rappeler
l'origine de votre question les fidèles
musulmans de la nuit ne doivent pas de
supporter la responsabilité des méfaits
il avait été ils ont été invités à
pouvoir se reporter pour eux lors
l'exercice de leur culte sur les
mosquées de torcy shell et busi situé à
proximité immédiate la mairie de l'ani
je le signe puisque nous parlons de
locaux avaient installé provisoirement
une tente pendant la période du ramadan
aujourd'hui je le dis clairement il
n'est pas acceptable que certains
s'autorisent dans un esprit de
provocation à prier dans la rue mais
dans le même temps vous comprendrez que
la réouverture d'un lieu de culte ne
puisse se faire qu'à condition qu'il ne
subsiste aucun lien avec les
associations
quand été dissoute la sous préfecture
est en contact avec la mairie
je suis à votre disposition pour
continuer en